now he also just posted this video today
we got a new q a Andrew K answers
questions from Aiden Ross so this is
back when Aiden visited Andrew in Dubai
Andrew oh this is unseen right there's a
couple questions I want to ask you sure
we can start some questions cool what
would you do if you had a start over
today
it's a very good question do I start oh
do I start over as me or do I do I start
over as me or do I start over as Joe
schmoe and I'm only going to answer what
would you do dancer Joe Schmo or Andrew
Tate that's a good question
if I had to start over yeah
I don't really like that question
because I think all the mistakes and um
but your Life Path makes you who you are
so I like everything that happened yeah
but if you like started your platform
from zero and you had to build it up
again would you just start these streams
and just like short form content like
basically the same strategy you did no I
think the I like the path that
everything I like my life path every
everything I think everything happens
for a reason and it was supposed to
happen I wouldn't change that what do
you think about what's your take on the
whole Andrew Tay movement do you think
that he's a positive influence for the
world yeah I think he's a net positive
for the world for a lot of reasons I
think that the the most obvious reason
is this attack on men and this attack on
masculinity and that's just an attack on
nature if you ask me if you guys have
Natural Instincts and Primal instincts
as we do as women and I think you should
be able to live them out and that
doesn't mean you know they make it seem
like being masculine means being rapey
and and mean and punching women in the
face and that's not what it means 98
says sunny looks so handsome in this
house
this family is crazy I don't know what
you're
let's continue thank you well I think we
live in an attention economy I think
that that's going to continue to be the
case up into the future I think that
things have now changed and if you can
manage to get attention you can somehow
monetize it if I wasn't the kind of
person who was good at garnering our
attention or didn't want to get
attention then I would find somebody who
is good at paying attention and I would
align myself with them
and then I would either find a way to
increase or monetize monetization
obviously being useful to them is one
thing but in my experience outside of of
course me everybody else who's good at
getting attention is [__] lazy and
they don't want to do anything else so I
would hate them I would let them be the
face and I would be the blood and guts
underneath and that's how I make a bunch
of money and you'll often see in the
best business relationships there's the
face of the business but the true
business behind it or a bunch of people
you don't know and it's the same with
everything so that was sure I'd find
somebody who was the face and got a lot
of attention and I'd sit down with him
somehow and say look here's how you make
this this is what you should do this is
what you should do this is what you
should do and they'd say and go yeah
maybe but I'm busy good I'm glad you're
busy this is my percent boom boom boom
boom and I'd make you figure it out at
what point Andrew did you realize that
you were famous
if people DM you or you kind of just
don't even open them anymore
sometimes I do
um I have one guy and he seemed like he
was in a really dark place uh and I
don't always respond to those but it
just seemed like I don't know I was just
like late at night and he was he was
saying he was going to kill himself and
I talked to him for a while just uh
telling him like what he should do I
just told him to stop being a [__] you
know and he ended up saying thank you I
was pretty harsh you know I said stop
being a [__] like your life is fine
like you live in a first world like this
is what you need to do tomorrow don't
have any negative thoughts go to the gym
tomorrow
um focus on the things you like doing
and every tomorrow like just go to sleep
and tomorrow when you wake up every time
you get a negative thought just think
it's something positive and like we talk
we but that you know oftentimes I don't
that's just one that sticks out and it
sticks out because that made me feel
good about myself I'm like look at me I
did something good changing lives yeah
hopefully I hope he didn't kill himself
if he did please go in the chat say I
didn't I'm still alive but uh you don't
read comments at all you don't you don't
reply whatsoever occasionally I do I
definitely recognize in public yeah I've
only gotten recognized a couple times
but nothing crazy you get recognized
like what every time you leave now
oh yeah it's I probably need a bodyguard
at this point I I think I need to I
think it's a nice I do not want to film
videos but yeah like pretty much does it
get weird
um like where you feel uh people are
just being totally disrespectful no
one's disrespected you know no I mean
like today I was sitting down having
breakfast and then some guy came with
like some shaving cream I think he was
doing a tick tock sponsor and he's like
what do you use yourself to shave with
my skin feels like a baby's butt I'm
like you want to feel babies butts like
what are you talking about and it's just
you know it was fine but I never have
any weird interactions like last night I
was out um with Myron after the stream
and like I'll walk around with my hood
on but then like five guys we were
walking across them I know my
demographic I know what they look like
and I'm like this bad happened to go wow
like we're on the sidewalk and it's just
like you're walking and then oh like I
was in New York one time and then this
guy's coming across and I'm there I'm
leaving like the doctor or something and
he's there with the hood on and he goes
whoa and if you're in New York and like
you know you have to kind of be up point
and then this guy just like he looks
scared as [__] sometimes you think
you're about to get mummed but it is
cool getting to the level where people
get like excited if you respond to them
they're like no way and it's like I
don't know man it's it's such a big
change so rapidly to have people think
that it's pretty yeah it hasn't happened
to me so I was out uh last month I was
out to dinner with um do you know I
don't know if you're familiar with the
sterniolo triplets they're not just
demographic that's not your demographic
or ours I mean they've got teenage girls
there's triplets we're I'm friends with
the mother Sonic played hockey with the
triplets oh they took talkers you were
talking about that yeah I mean they're
talking they've got combined like four
million Subs like they're huge for girls
and I was out to dinner with the mother
and these two teenage girls came up and
were like oh my God
it's mother and they made her get up and
take pictures with them and they were so
they took pictures together and they
each had to have their own individual
picture with her and it was pretty cute
but
um was it that's when I realized that
the power of this social media
thing and it's a totally different kind
of Fame and a totally different kind of
accessibility than movie stars and TV
stars had when I was growing was it
weird the first time you got recognized
because that was weird for me like
normally when you know when you don't
get recognized you're not like if
someone sees you you think you know them
you know what I mean
like did that happen I was happier
um when I got recognized I was like 14
and I was at this gaming convention it's
funny I actually met KSI wow at that
gaming convention I was like I was 14
because I've been doing it for a long
time and now like KSI like you know
there's a whatever
um but I was a fan of him back then a
lot of the people that like had beef
with now did you watching fan I bought
his merch I watched I used to do vape
nation in class like I was a huge fan
and now he's like this is just it's
violin it's like bro this we got it
literally one of my biggest YouTube
Inspirations I like the guy disgusts me
now
um it's not crazy he really went to hell
with himself dude and he used to be like
he was like an OG like red pill in a way
he got canceled it was so funny you get
canceled and you sell out but yeah I was
at this gaming convention I was 14 this
guy's like oh you're a sneako you got
but yeah I am let's take a picture I
took a picture with him you know like uh
like do you want an autograph and he's
like nah I'm good
that's a good question I don't know I
never really intended to be famous
famous but uh but when did you realize
that you're like oh one of the times it
hit me in regards to how famous I was is
when I was with Steven Seagal
um two weeks ago students have always
here oh gee but two weeks ago you knew
you were more that's your generation
type I don't even know I don't think I'd
have been here
I don't know one Steven Seagal movie
everyone everyone in my generation knows
Steven Seagal like a household name
everyone all of us yes
I was about to call you a boomer but
then I'm like let me not be
disrespectful of course I did I'm saying
one of the times it occurred to me okay
I was with Steven Seagal two weeks ago
and by the way Steven Seagal is a
[__] hero you guys didn't ever meet
your Heroes you know him they say never
meet your Heroes [__] me she's a g yeah
right Ice Cold anyway he was saying bro
uh I'd love to take a picture of my son
they're talking about you in school that
I'm like yeah cool whatever I'm asking I
met Stephen Sun took the picture I said
I heard the talk about in school goes
yeah we did a whole class on you and uh
how your effect on culture etc etc so
where do you go to school he said Ulan
Batar which is the capital of Mongolia
did you see that Mongolian alien [__]
like they said that they're putting like
two billion dollars into like you know
teaching people that Andrew Tate is bad
did you see that in the UK do you think
that's real yeah it is I saw a
parliament hearing a teacher get uh
standing up and asking for funding from
uh the UK Parliament but like where is
that money going like what like two
billion dollars don't you just give them
a new curriculum yeah it's funny that
the country is ridden with homelessness
and drugs and there's all this problem
and they're going to focus on
re-educating people about agitate in
China Tick-Tock as you guys know is all
educational videos all of it kids are
allowed in China there's no people
dancing no no making a salad in a oh
yeah they want us to cut off our pieces
and changes Western society's worried
about [__] like that instead of
actually dominating the world as they
should be the way China is but anyway
somebody said how big is it
Brooke if you do one more gay no no how
big is your bank account that's how big
is your bank accounts I know you think
you're smart you think you're smart do
you actually think you're smart a little
bit do you believe like I'm smart
um do you know how many partners you've
had and like at all or is that too
personal for you I do know but I don't
think it's that important actually no
I'll change it I think as a man's sexual
experience is very important how many
bodies do you have okay I think as a
woman that the number one thing that men
value in women is innocence I think
innocence is very very attractive and
it's not just about sex as a man when
you find a woman if you were to build
your ideal woman from the ground up you
want to be able to give her experiences
and show her she's never done exactly
you want to show her things she's never
done for sure in every room not just
sexually and everything else you want to
be the first person to take our first
class first person to put in a five-star
hotel yeah first person to take her
tonight private jet yeah you want to be
the guy to show her the world of course
so and that also includes sexually so
you like the idea of a woman with less
experience so you can show her things a
woman's like I know all of it yeah
you're a bit like do you do you agree
with that I I'm speaking to a lot of
Christians and America first people and
uh in the a24 campaign it's really
against fornication I think that's the
biggest disagreement that traditional
conservatives have with what Andrew
talks about and I see the point that he
is promoting fornication for men but not
for women and that's that is a double
standard and also so like you don't need
to have that type of experience in order
to to have a happy marriage like you
don't need to be with hundreds of women
in order to be happy like he's promoting
men to go out and and [__] and have sex
all the time but is that is that really
necessary like everything else I I
understand personal responsibility
getting in the gym doing hard work
um not being depressed focusing
providing for your family all that I
agree with but do you do you really
think that to become a man you need a
lot of sexual experience I don't I don't
think so I I figured you would yeah and
and I don't and I don't say that a lot
of sexual experience is a bad thing for
a man either but you know on the one
hand he's like who are these when you
know women should keep themselves pure
and men should sleep around but like so
are they all just sleeping with the same
few girls who are off the rails like
what's the deal there I mean you can't
have it both ways you're talking about
like the the forehead [__]
it's like his point with that is like if
women did have their body count on their
forehead it would fix a lot of the
problems because the
the guys would have to build themselves
up to be able like women would have [__]
man I know what you're saying men would
have to work harder and build themselves
up if women weren't so easy that's right
so it would just like raise the status
of all men you know what I mean like men
would all have to build themselves up to
get the girls you see what I'm saying am
I tripping right now I understand what
you're saying that it would be better
because then women would have to be open
about their sexual experiences I
understand that part that women should
preserve their innocence but I'm asking
like do you think genuinely that to
become a man you need a lot of sexual
experience I think it helps a lot of
people and I'm telling a lot of like I
have a lot of insults I watch my watch
My Stream and I think it's important it
will get people out of the cage uh well
out of that box I've met a lot of guys
and like that they need to approach and
they need to talk to women just so that
they have more social experience with
life but you don't need that in order to
become uh because people that I know
that are leaders like a lot of them are
just virgins and they just they've never
gotten autistic about women and so they
don't need that that I don't think
that's as necessary as he makes it out
to be I agree with you I don't think
it's just sorry and I also think to when
it gets to a certain point there's a
Tipping Point where it becomes damaging
to Future relationships the way it does
the same way that he says it does for
women I think if a man is with too many
women he just gets used to the variety
you know he never wants a box of
chocolates where it's it's 20 of the
same chocolate he always wants the
variety
and I think that that's gonna that
that'll affect his relationship with one
woman and it's that you know women have
this you know there's this thing you see
in movies and in songs or like she
caught the bad boy she caught the guy
that was with all the women and she was
the one that stole his heart like that
song Fooled Around and Fell in Love But
that's a bunch of [__] because that
guy is also
emotionally damaged when it comes to
being in a community do you ever see
yourself being loyal to one girl
no
why not
um I mean maybe it's possible right now
I don't see it in the west and like the
girls that I'm around right now American
women
um I was just funny like that's this is
a Gen X song American Woman this is what
I say man get out of my way like I'm
like these women are are just absolutely
lost and they believe in a lot of
garbage and I don't like talking to most
of them you know I'll fake it I'll be
like oh what's yours and then we're just
talking about nothing and she's telling
me about the cookies she baked and stuff
and I gotta pretend like I care
um yeah I just it doesn't really like
why would I be loyal to that girl you
know like I don't like this girl she has
she has a Tinder she's been with like
she's a feminist but she's also an
empowered sex positive blah blah blah I
maybe one day if I move to another
country I could reconsider that but
American women absolutely not I could
not settle down and get married I have
yet to meet a girl like in the west that
could convince me of that have you
noticed girls like throwing themselves
at you way more since you you're blow up
in the last few months no it's been the
same it's been I mean a cup but like
DM's nothing really it's all dudes bro
my DMs are all dudes
dudes I have to like scroll like I'll be
like looking through like like okay
let's see like I have to like type in
Miami look up a flag of like a country
of a girl that uh that you know dude I
just said that's that's a hack if you
look up like say you're into Ukrainian
girls search the Ukrainian flag and
you're following list and then you can
just sort through
yeah but
um no it hasn't really been that much
different and I I think that people
overestimate how much clout really works
for that bro you dude that that's that's
the thing about Idols so like when I
made my first like big sum of money
about a year ago now I'm like bro I got
a few hundred thousand like I'm getting
girls when I'm back at school and then I
I'm like you know all right well maybe
it wasn't just the money maybe I need to
spend the money to get the girls I buy a
convertible I'm like I can't have a
convertible with no girls still no girls
like and it's just everything that you
think is gonna take you there at the end
of the day it's it's really all just in
your head I I feel like God's protecting
you from girls because they're just a
distraction
[Music]
Sunny from girls no like loads and loads
of them I'm not saying that he doesn't
and you too like you're saying in the in
the deal
no no I think it's it's it is truly for
both of your best interests to continue
to build yourselves as men and you know
you get the occasional girl here and
there and yeah
is too much of a distraction you get in
a relationship she's going to try to
suck the life out of you don't do it
succubus
what's it called a succubus oh okay
that's like a demon word for a girl who
just tries to suck away your energy yeah
it's just not yeah like especially right
now I think in recommendation like guys
who are 18 to 25 my opinion the best
thing is to not get into a relationship
is to not focus on women at all is just
work on yourself become the best person
that you could possibly be and then
everything else like the social
experience the RIS and like becoming
more social that all comes with becoming
better that's it does and it also when
you're when you're 25 something switches
in your brain
that like your brain is fully developed
but you know my father used to say to me
all the time you know what you know kid
you don't know [__] oh we said that and
when I was 25 is the day that I realized
that I didn't know [__] and he was right
and I and I grew up and I realized that
my perspective was going to continuously
change and I was going to grow and I
could talk to older people and take
advice and I just became a different
person and that happens a lot and so and
I've seen that almost exact number in a
lot of people so
I'd say you know stay out of serious
relationships before then if you can and
I'd like to ask you again in 10 years do
you see yourself that question do you
see yourself you know settling with one
woman no you're going to be a different
dude of course right now like I
generally I don't have a really positive
outlook on women in the West
and I that's just well I can't imagine
why I mean look at them I didn't meet
one girl my whole freshman it wasn't
that I wasn't pulling girls like if I
went out and I was talking to girls
clarifying this I was getting them but
you think like when you get money and
like you get a car and stuff they're
gonna start like throwing themselves at
you or you're gonna get more DMS or even
like you know a 150 000 Subs on YouTube
now 50k on Instagram like it really
doesn't mean you think at all quality
women with brains and and real value
they're not going to throw themselves at
you well that's the thing too it's like
you see the girls that are posting
themselves half naked and you're like oh
my God let me shoot a DM but it's like
you don't want that girl like I think
you know what I mean you don't want the
girl that's posting herself naked online
what's a private Instagram I've been
with like you know the hot even the one
that's sending you a private Instagram
sketch
I've been with like the girls on like oh
sorry Mom that um have like the big Tick
Tock following for posting their body
and [__] and it's like they're just hoes
man just hoes just hoes 98 says what's
the main difference between now when
your channel is the same size as sunny
it's funny because I saw you did that
street interview
um out in Boston Common well not in um
next uh South Station in Boston Faneuil
Hall yeah is that where it is right
outside of South Station yeah yeah and I
remember doing a street interview in
that same spot at the same age and I was
like oh yeah this and you had like your
channel was around the same size so
um what I I mean I think Sonny's on a
similar path to what I was doing just
based off of that yeah all of it yeah
okay
um but I think as a man it's the
opposite and I also think that women
like men I was gonna say that yeah I
think for a man like like he said we
want innocent women but if a woman abuse
that's a woman she don't want a man that
has never had sex of course you know
what's actually interesting it's
interesting they asked I don't know
where I saw this it was a long time ago
but I saw it was a survey they were
asking virgin women if they want a
virgin man and even a virgin woman says
they want to be dominated right no it's
going to be tall they want to be taught
they want man to guide them through the
process and experience part of being a
man is experience and and that's why
even in very subtle ways the reason
women love scars on men something has
happened to him it's experience right
yeah so when I say it's not important I
take that back it's a man's sexual
experience and sexual uh the fact that
you've been around the block to a degree
is actually very important yeah but also
I'm not going to say a number because a
lot of dudes lie about the number etc
etc but I had a webcam company and stuff
it's extensive is there an estimate
okay not bad but but I I do I don't
think that number is that important and
I also think the number of girls in
um Romania like you saw them with like
all their girlfriends and stuff right
yeah
like do you think you could ever pull
that off where you have like a whole
Throne of girlfriends so Andrew was more
like cautious at the time because it was
right after the cancellation so he
didn't even want to bring in new ones
yeah Tristan so like he was just still
adding to the roster Tristan
legitimately had like probably 30 I've
I've watched some of Tristan's courses
it's crazy stuff the PHD course I
haven't seen that yeah it's honestly
like pretty good information it's not
creepy at all like the way that they cut
it up yeah Chinese had six to seven
hundred is uh but you guys are me
watching like crazy but who can
I don't know that's what I'm saying like
it's like one man texts me twice a day
I'm like to hell with him oh get off my
back I I can't even imagine having like
30 floating around who's I mean
that's that's part of the game is that
you don't text him that much and then
they're all competing for your attention
constantly like when I saw them they're
all like sitting around like just
waiting for like a glimmer you would
probably talk to one of his girlfriends
maybe like
10 words in a day like just like they
would be come here like coffee like it
was just really simple stuff like water
like that was it you know and then they
were like did this thing like they were
just like waiting for like little
[__] Birds following around like
flocking around for you know like when
seagulls smell food at the beach and
they're just like hovering around and
then you walk away and they'll dive in
that was that it's just like all these
seagulls just want his attention back
pay for attention yeah that's the game
you don't he doesn't he barely needs you
don't really need to talk to him that
much so these aren't regular girls and
they're certainly not American women but
the thing is it's is it not a similar
relationship for like like look at like
my uncle and he has a wife that doesn't
even speak English and he doesn't speak
Spanish they're just like like it speaks
English a little bit but it's kind of a
relationship like that where you're not
having like the most intellectual
conversation right you just have a nice
partnership I think that is far better
than what what's Nico just laid out what
if they had a bunch of a bunch of uses
would be hilarious oh Jesus no thanks
wrap their heads around it all day long
and why that game is fun for them it
just doesn't sound fun to me I mean I I
I I would treat a dog better than that
than it did seem kind of fun for Tristan
like I'm not sure I mean I think I've
already talked about this but like he
would invite them all to the club and
he'd be like let's see what's about to
happen like you're just waiting for them
to like he seemed like he kind of
enjoyed the
the spunker I don't know I don't I don't
want to meet watch like that but right I
know what you mean though yeah it's like
a game yeah this is sex is important I
think that you can learn a lot about
women it's not just sleep with them you
need to have a whole bunch of girls who
just slept with need to have
relationships you need to have that time
you've got your heart broken you need to
let that one chick who [__] did some
[__] got away with some slight [__] so
no other [__] can finesse you that and
you get to a point in life and
truthfully as a man you hit your peak in
your late 30s
that's when you're most attractive to
women yeah can I ask you questions you
have gone your heart this is my first
question you've got your heart of course
I agree Every Man's had their heart
broken but you have to there's different
to use it as a learning experience you
have to learn you have to let it use it
to fuel you I've said this now every any
man who said he hasn't hasn't had their
heart broken this line okay but there's
two there's two kinds of men the people
who have their heart broken and let it
destroy them and there's the men who
have their heart broken can't sleep so
they're in the gym three times a day
this that's it if you walk into the gym
right now and find the [__] guys
training hardest he's probably lost his
[__] he's right you're not wrong
because the reason he's doing it bro I
remember when I lost my [__] the
motivation you you find the guy who's
[__] going nuts
you're right you're right because it can
make you great you're right because when
I broke my girl you know I hit the gym
soon
she obviously wasn't all that gee I
don't know who you were [__] but look
you're not surprised you can't tell the
six-packs coming in and what happened to
me
but no but I know you lost Halloween but
what's actually truly interesting is
crazy I I think that I'm like although I
think women have big gym motivation
right right now like what's when you're
tired as [__] and you don't want to go
like what's what's getting you to the
gym is it like honestly like your
Instagram stories are probably a big
part yeah my Instagram story to be
honest like seeing all the guys that are
motivating and like I could have been
eating a burger could have been watching
Netflix could have been watching only
fans I could have been sipping it like
I'll be in between sets like [__] check
the Instagram stories and everybody's
there like fire each other up that's
like well these guys are doing and I
don't see guys like cripples get in
there like one Peggy legged dudes people
with casts on like they're they're in
the cold doing push-ups like guys at
work shout out to the electricians that
are there doing push-ups in between like
fixing someone's house I'm like bro how
could I have any excuse if these guys
are finding time to do it you know I
know a Navy SEAL that lives a few blocks
away we should do a video or some [__]
where we do like a full Navy SEAL
workout with him because that'll just
like break you down it's crazy should I
stream that that'd be cool he's a dope
guy
Navy Seals don't mess around
we'll see yodastectomy said amazing I
wonder shout out to Chris Rumble CEO one
bull in the chat women and men happen I
think that all life paths to a degree
are semi-similar yeah we end up in
different positions
and some are in blah blah but I think if
you take the average man in the western
world
there's one or two or maybe three
possible stories we all start off with
nothing most men are born with zero
value you can be born with Rich parents
and be a little bit it doesn't matter
yeah but you're born with biscuit no
value you fall in love with that [__]
in school who wants to jock and knock
you with an older guy and then yeah you
get your girl she breaks your heart and
then most men have had a pretty similar
story me you you can name a little of
course but it's just how those events
affect you and how you internalize them
and how you use them to become who you
are I would say most men go through
similar obstacles and different types of
Life Experiences I think we have yeah I
think we have similar building blocks
similar pieces of Lego and how we put
ourselves together is is what makes us
us completely yeah I appreciate it
what's your end game goal life Mr Tate I
think that
I don't think although I think we're
getting into a position that's worse
than ever I think throughout all of
human history every single man that's
ever been alive has been living through
a period in which he feels like the
world is ending I'm sure the people who
are alive during World War II felt like
the world was ending so you're sure
about the people who were fighting off
the Mongol hordes felt the world was
ending I'm sure that in the 1700s when
it became legal to know not wear a suit
when you go outside they probably
thought this is massively detrimental to
society the world is ending we've always
felt we've always felt like the world's
ending yeah we always thought the world
was ending and I think that basically
the best thing you can do is procreate
and try and create people who replicate
yourself and your values to the best of
your ability so my end goal is to have
20 Sons with my name and things like me
that's my what if you have a daughter
that's authentic why would I not want a
dollar just curious you said 20 cents
yes I would I would love to have
daughters absolutely but it's my sons
are going to carry my name and carry my
legacy so obviously you need both but
that that's the end goals did you ever
experience something in his well I want
to say history that's what makes sound
like really old but did you ever
experience something in your life that
was like the West has done the world is
over
what was that well there's always
something 9 11. I don't know that no no
I 911 was it was devastating and
heartbreaking on so many levels
the
um you know I grew up in Brooklyn and
those buildings were an important part
of my life I was there too
um my you know my first communion like
my parents wanted to throw me a party
and I was like no I don't want to party
I wanna I want dinner at windows on the
world and so we had this like nice fancy
dinner with the family up at the
restaurant on top and another we had a
couple family parties there and my
father's business uh we had a limousine
business and they were their main
clients were uh Kenner Fitzgerald so we
were we were the help you know but so
those my my father and all of our cars
and drivers were always at those
buildings they were just really really
in in my life and um
so when that happened that that was it
was heartbreaking and I knew people that
died and it was terrifying but I didn't
feel like that sense of the world is
ending or all doomsday I feel now
probably for the first time that there's
a real societal collapse that's
happening so I'm not being like
pessimistic by thinking that the West is
over I don't think it's over but I think
I'm partially in denial because I see
like the fall of Rome happening again
but I also see so many signs I also yeah
no the signs are all there and it's
happening but I also see people starting
to come up and rise up and stand up to
save it why are they calling me Walter
White Jr
[Laughter]
so-called my boy
this is it that I was afraid of world
war three I didn't know what the hell
was gonna happen we had Anthrax being
mailed out around the country we're
afraid to open our mail we thought we're
gonna hit again couldn't we're terrified
to fly it was a nightmare but I didn't
feel like it was the end of the world
now the I feel like the West is dying
but people are starting to rise up you
got everybody everyday Joe's like me
standing up and being like go ahead
cancel me I don't give a [__]
[Music]